can you unpack
what some of the stuff you saw i mean
you know sometimes i sit there and i
let's just say i'm going through my news
feed and i'll see a
mother or a father beating a six month
old kid i'm like why is this thing here
it's got 52 million views i'm like this
what's the purpose of leaving this on or
you'll see some bizarre videos that make
zero sense for them to be on
but they have those things up there what
did you see and i can only imagine as a
user what that makes me feel when i walk
away what are some of the things you saw
i saw a lot
the best way to explain it is
if you've been to many of these sites i
know some of them are not around anymore
but there were sites such as um
best gore chaotic with a k there was the
live leaks
um
there were many other sites that i could
think of like hard candy and you would
have these uh videos mainly of just
these horrific acts that could range
from child pedophilia to putting
fireworks in a dog's mouth and then them
setting it up on fire
to um
fathers making their daughters have sex
with pigs and then
stabbing the pig
while the daughter was
having sex with the pig
um i saw those types of videos day by
day a lot of these had to deal with
bestiality abuse against animals
um i also specialized in
during the summer it was in china the
dog eating festival so
the facebook allowed these different
types of videos and photos up there of
people that were cooking skinning eating
dogs alive
because facebook said that due to the
cultural differences it would be the
equivalent of us having pictures of cows
or chickens
so they allowed people to basically just
mutilate dogs on live stream
through video through photos
for the sake of this dog food festival
that they have in china every summer
so
you see that video you see the dog
eating festival in china what else was
there so so far it's sexual
exploitation animal
any other are you seeing also killing
are you seeing like live shooting what
else are some of the things you guys are
saying uh there were plenty of live
shootings in fact a lot of them came
from the united states having to do
between gang wars people that would um
just have their cell phones out in the
middle of a shootout
there would also be a lot of content
from the middle east of people that were
um stoning pedophiles to death or people
that were basically just beating their
kids until they were black and blue on
the face and their eyes were popping out
of their head
a lot of the content that had to do with
the middle east usually had to deal with
beating women and children
or stoning people that they perceived as
doing a wrongdoing
there was in fact this one video that i
was working with content-wise
and it was a person gonna put a gun in
another man's mouth and then pulled the
trigger
and you could visibly see
the innards going through the back of
his skull
and i actioned it to delete it and there
was another person that like checks the
moderators checks the checker so to
speak
and this person made the claim that
what we saw was not actually the visible
innards going out but bullet fragments
and i made the argument that it's
clearly white these are skull fragments
coming out of the back of their head
they're not silver they're not bullet
holes
and this person actually said that i was
wrong and that video was allowed to stay
on there because of that
so
a lot of a lot more of the content had
to do with the sexual exploitation a lot
of it dealt with children that were
online and they were basically being
groomed by pedophiles to come meet them
in person
oh there was also an incident with organ
harvesting videos so a lot of these
children in other countries
were basically being ripped apart alive
and they were having their organs taken
out without screaming and i remember how
bad it was that day because everybody
had to come into the main area and calm
everybody down there were like
people that were throwing up on the
floor like people that were just
screaming and crying wait these are your
co-workers who are throwing up on the
floor yes and um
i remember one of our team leads was
telling us how we were going to be
getting more
graphic content specifically because
facebook couldn't keep up with the
amount that they were getting
so they were telling us that like the
floodgates were opening so we were just
going to be dealing with graphic content
all the time in my department
so i got two questions let me go to the
one uh first
you know when
cops and cops are known for having a
very high divorce rate
because the life of a cop is not the
most glamorous life you know all we see
is you know what they're doing we see it
on tv good cops bad cups all this stuff
but they have a very high divorce rate
the life sucks from what many of my
friends talk to me about
a person who's a divorce attorney
you're
not going to be able to have
uh you're constantly talking about
divorces and if you're married you're
going to come home and all you're
thinking about is you're probably next
because your entire life is about
divorces i was being recruited to be a
special forces at the 18 delta fifth
group at fort campbell kentucky and they
asked me to go interview with other 18
deltas
and the guy was telling me he says you
ever planning on getting married and
fallen in love i said of course he says
don't ever become special forces because
you can't you're psychologically going
to be off i'm like i'm cycling so you're
psychologically going to be out that's
going to mess with you that was one
interview then i went to the next guy
then the next guy the next guy
some jobs you take they're going to mess
with you
but this is different there's a
difference between you watching
you know certain videos and certain
articles versus seeing this how are you
guys psychologically affected by this
when you're doing this eight hours a day
and you're going home how are you
handling that how is it affecting you
uh i was actually doing this ten hours a
day uh specifically because they needed
extra hands on deck for the extra two
hours to do this
so i was there always a bit longer than
most other people were specifically
because of the department i worked in um
just talking about the mental
health of the people that i worked with
it was not good within the building
so there were people that were smearing
feces on the bathroom walls there were
people that were
defecating in the sinks and the urinals
there were people that would just be
like
smoking drinking
in the middle of the day in their cars
during their break period
there was always talk about people using
the break room for sexual activities
there was always people that were
bringing in all sorts of illegal
substances to take while they were doing
this stuff uh just the mental health of
my coworkers was not well because of all
this
specifically going through we were
supposed to have a counselor there some
mental health therapist to help i was
only able to see this person once
and it wasn't even the actual one that
worked there it was someone that was
just filling in
and i remember he flat out told me
i don't know how i can help you guys
because he did not know what to do he
did not see the type of content we were
seeing
and he just flat out said i'm filling in
but i don't know how to help you guys
because all of this was new to him as
well and i never met the actual person
that was supposed to be on board with us
every day
and a lot of my co-workers i spoke with
never met this person either
i'm not even sure if this person really
existed or maybe this person was only
there like a few hours a few days
so i have no real confirmation on this
person ever actually helping somebody
through a tough time they've had there
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]